aquí
i
[Música]
hola qué tal es como un gran placer que
llegamos aquí este estudio todos los
viernes para reunirnos con ustedes con
leonora chapman y leonardo gimeno les
presentamos hoy canalda en las américas
que hace nuestro programa semanal de
este viernes 6 de septiembre en vivo y
en directo por facebook live youtube en
nuestro sitio internet
rc y net punto o sea la visión en
nuestra aplicación que no se olvide
está despierto bueno bienvenida a
leonora bienvenido al mente de todo el
mundo y claro un caluroso saludo a todos
ustedes a yakarta es cierto que hay acá
aquí ya comienza a refrescarse la
temperatura pero por allá seguramente
que se está recalentando argentina-chile
fresquito recuerdo hace dos semanas
gente que se quejaba del calor
porque además tengo la impresión que
este verano pasó pero como una ráfaga de
viento prácticamente no me parece que se
fue rapidísimo hubo mucha lluvia es
cierto pero muchos días de calor también
no nos quejamos pero es cuando se pero
están podemos es tan cortitas duración
corto el verano es tan largo el invierno
[Risas]
las intenciones y las intenciones de
bueno un caluroso saludo de todas forma
para todos ustedes allá del otro lado de
la cámara y de los micrófonos y bueno y
muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros y por su alta fidelidad que
para nosotros pues es la razón de ser de
nuestro programa y nosotros pues venimos
para eso no para los fieles exactos para
los fieles y saber de dónde viene
fidelidad de fe
uno tiene claro que del latín de la
tenencia de uno tiene fe a la otra
persona por ejemplo si ellos no tienen
fe a nosotros mucho decir
con alusión también a la fidelidad no de
la fe pero la fidelidad del sonido
bueno entonces vamos a entrar con
nuestro canal en las américas café o el
castor cibernético de este viernes y no
se le o nar 2 y tú tienes alguna
efeméride por ahí siempre piensa hacer
parte el 4 de septiembre porque aparte
me equivoqué de hoja traje una que no
tiene nada que ver de un mensaje a que
todo lo que digo va a ser de memoria el
día de la sexualidad
y es una fecha marcada por la onu para
justamente la educación sexual y para
remarcar la importancia de una
sexualidad sana
/ obviamente en puntualmente entre los
jóvenes y por supuesto para los adultos
también pero se tiene en cuenta ese día
como el día de la sexualidad el 4 de
septiembre y en otros países festejan
hoy el día del sexo oral
porque es parte de la sexualidad también
hace parte de la sexualidad la misma
semana y tiene que ver con en realidad
es un poco más entre comidas chistoso
porque es el 6 del 99
probablemente alguien en las naciones
unidad lo practique pero lo que sí me
parece importante aparte del chiste es
que en naciones unidas haya designado un
día especial para la sexualidad en esos
países en tantos países desarrollados
incluso aquí como en canadá algunas
provincias se está pensando en cambiar
la educación en las escuelas o donde
antes existía educación retirarla había
una propuesta del gobierno de ontario
por lo que regresó a otro lado entonces
que es muchísimas protestas aquí en
canadá de padre
educadores justamente porque la
educación sexual es fundamental no sólo
no sólo para tener una buena relación
con la persona que elige evitar caer en
trampa
y la locura de escuchar un programa de
radio hace un par de días atrás y
hablaban justamente de temas que tienen
que ver con la sexualidad y esta gente
decía
la sexualidad sigue siendo un tabú y hoy
más que nunca tenemos que saber por
ejemplo algún personaje importante el
papá el papá nació del sexo o sea que
nació del sexo y por supuesto ahora es
el jueves es una cosa tan natural es una
cosa que tendría que ser tan básica y
todavía hay barreras que no permiten que
uno lo piense con naturalidad es la
historia de ver películas y werder
ejecuciones en las películas de ciencia
ficción y que los chicos de 12 o 13 años
estén viendo esas películas y después
sale un sale una mujer desnuda un hombre
desnudo y le tapamos los ojos porque
porque no se puede ver el cuerpo humano
a mí me parece ridículo o sea me parece
ridículo que deje el acceso a tanta
violencia que vea por día y no a una
cosa absolutamente que se encuentra más
natural la violencia que justamente hace
poco tiempo estábamos conversando en la
sección estaba paloma estaban ustedes
conversando
sobre la importancia de la educación
sexual porque las redes sociales están
invadiendo a los jóvenes con la
pornografía y expertos canadienses ya
están lanzando a presencias de que los
niños hoy son más educados a través de
la pornografía que educados en las
escuelas e incluso en las casas también
es como que una veces abandona eso no
sabe cómo entonces es fundamental para
evitar además que caigan en trampas no
estábamos comentando el caso de una una
app una aplicación que es muy popular
entre los jóvenes y había una niña y por
eso estábamos comentando hija de una
colega nuestra que no debe tener ni
siquiera 12 años en esa aplicación para
niños le saltó le aparecieron de repente
imágenes pornográficas y las niñas de
largo a llorar es decir si vos no haces
prevención si no hablas con estos niños
y estos jóvenes terminan teniendo una
visión errónea de lo que es una
sexualidad
y por supuesto lo que debería ser algo
tan sano claro y ahora con las nuevas
tecnologías pesaje es algo que tenemos
que tenerlo en cuenta porque tratar de
pensar que es el que la que la
pornografía no le puede llegar por sus
teléfonos celulares tratar de ocultar la
luz del sol que uno sabe desde desde
chicos yo creo que en mi casa jamás
hablamos de educación sexual cultura
chico o sea todo no aprendí lo aprendí
pero el grupo de amigos pero no
estábamos expuestos a lo que estamos
expuestos hoy llevamos a los que
nuestros hijos están expuestos hoy con
la internet que esto está la droga
mantas y todo se puede hacer rápido y
todo se puede esconder y todo o sea es
realmente una locura que no podamos
cada que cada que insistir en la
educación sexual para que esto no sea un
golpe y para que no se dé cuenta y para
que las criaturas tengan la capacidad de
discernir qué es lo que está bien lo que
está mal la imaginación y de un producto
cinematográfico y qué es lo que
realmente sucede en la realidad con el
cuerpo y tal son son elementos básicos
que hay que discutir y que creo que
bueno en este caso la onu tiene tuvo muy
buen tino a partir del 2010 de poner el
4 de septiembre como el día de la
educación sexual y eso es extremadamente
importante fantástico entonces vamos a
suspender nuestro curso de educación
cortita al juez de septiembre argentina
también se celebra el día del inmigrante
en argentina
pero ya no hay un país que no tenga
población inmigrantes no no no me pero
y en lugares donde la inmigración
sino primeros centros base y hoy a mí
por ejemplo todo cuando viaje la primera
vez hace muchísimos años a parís me
pareció extraordinario él caminando
justo sigue para el día el primero para
el primero de mayo era la movilización
para el día del trabajo y me pareció
extraordinario ver tanto color tanto
acento tanta tanta gente hablando
diferentes idiomas espacios guau y
cuando llegamos a montreal montreal es
lo mismo pero no se ve en otras ciudades
no se ve en otras grandes ciudades está
bien o sea hay si un flujo migratorio
importantísimo pero creo que hay lugares
donde esos se vive mucho más y bueno
entonces continuamos acá con nuestros
temas de honor y en tenis
el tenis me gusta pero además esto es es
algo inédito aquí en canadá aunque una
canadiense llegue a la final de los
internacionales de tenis de estados
unidos es el caso de bianca andrés
19 años recién cumplidos ya el año
pasado a finales del año pasado estaba
180 en el mundo hoy está entre los 10
primeros los 17 y sideral por la paz que
enjuagar cuarto lugar si gana el
tornillo nada si gana mañana sábado
contra serena huella es fulgurante es
fulgurante lo que está haciendo y que
todo el mundo estaba un poco hablando
aquí de félix oye que era el joven que
la gente hace al jazz y que tiene
también 19 años acaba de cumplir que por
supuesto las esperanzas están puestas en
el lado masculino en el pulso por el
capo le dicen sapo que esta visión de él
es de ontario de sapo y félix es de
quebec y ella es de ontario también de
kirchner creo pues las esperanzas
estaban puestos los dos varones y de
repente esta niña está surgiendo es
increíble vi algunos partidos por la
televisión
lo que me asombra de bianca andrés es la
fuerza mental que tiene está perdiendo y
no abandona en lo abandona y esto se dio
se está viendo en la personalidad y
suavidad también no fue el torneo pasado
que ganó la vida se acercó y le dé un
abrazo realmente un enfoque mucho más
exacto exacto no sólo peces
pero ella ganó el torneo este este año
en indianápolis si no me equivoco que es
considerado entre los torneos más
importantes después de los gran slam
entonces no es que viene y les regalan y
sólo bien si gana entonces este sábado
va a estar ella en la final con serena
huella
yo particularmente le gustaba lucas que
dice respecto al comentario inicial
sobre la fidelidad de los oyentes en lo
personal cada semana deseo que llegue el
viernes para poder verlos y escucharlos
pero también puede ser lo largo en
uruguay siempre está ahí es un top fan
me encanta cuando el simbolito top fun
aparece arriba al costado el nombre me
parece fantástico
muchísimas gracias muchísimas gracias
hasta correcta son locas ellos estaba de
mando lucas ya por el apellido es el que
estuvo jugando en montreal cuando fue el
campeonato de tenis para terminar de los
varones que fue este verano el que llegó
a la final de dobles y ganó la final fue
zeballos de argentina y ahora ceballos
está creo que llegó a la final
no no estoy siguiendo el que seguía era
el otro argentino dijo que la historia
es preciosa
también porque escrito sí pero la
historia del es exquisita porque los
padres no tenían dinero para solventarla
su carrera de tenista y se le veía cepa
de tenista y lo que hicieron los padres
el padre lo acompañaba a todos pedían
plata prestada lo acompañaba a los
torneos y lentillas camisetas vendía
cosas en la salida del torneo para
juntar dinero para devolverlo
y ahora está 2018 es una buena inversión
muy monetarios no no pero sólo se ahora
pierde en segunda ronda y el heca en 300
mil dólares pero en aquel momento para
porque es muy difícil la vida del
tenista que recién empieza para poder
realmente al senado y para pasar de
torneo los torneos importantes lo que
han puntaje hay que pagarlos hay que
pagar
el alojamiento hay que pagar la
inscripción
esto es una complicación para esa gente
que recién empieza muy bien y yo lo que
me gustaría resaltar como insólito es
esta este vídeo que se volvió viral y de
un hombre en la ciudad de toronto
robándose una bicicleta
pero no fue en la medianoche fue en
pleno día delante de todo el mundo y ahí
lo vemos al tipo un hombre
entonces si un taxi está pasando y lo
vio y firmó un videíto que vamos a ver
un poquito más tarde del tipo pues ahí
trabajando delante de todo el mundo en
20 segundos al parecer rompió el candado
pero qué velocidad eso es un cerrar de
abril abril y se pierde y bueno
agarre comenzó porque me sucedió alguna
vez te robaste en el siglo par de años
no voy a verme rojas de una bicicleta
pero prácticamente mucha gente pudo
haber pensado eso y es que en la llave
de mi candado se dañó y había amarrado
mi bicicleta en la calle sant catering
que no está muy lejos de acá y cuando
fui a sacar el candado no fui capaz
porque no funcionaba la llave y total
que ha mirado
acá y ahora va a ver que el taxista el
taxista el se da cuenta que el taxista
lo está firmando y se enoja si no me
dejan trabajar tranquilo
así
entonces fui y le presté a un amigo una
sierra igualita a la que me pediste
prestado y le pedí prestado porque no
podía desencadenar mi bicicleta no le
podía quitar el candado entonces fui y
me conecté a la frutería que están las
[Música]
eléctrico y finalmente pues pude romper
la luz del día y la gente que pasa
cuatro de la tarde nadie me dijo nada
también podría dudarlo y no se puede
acusar a las personas tampoco de
prejuiciosas hacia vos entonces con esa
pinta de europeo que tienes y nadie te
dijo nada de hombre
mayor
[Risas]
javier gonzález nungaray desde méxico
dice este en este horario estoy
trabajando pero siempre me doy algo de
tiempo para este programa que me encanta
desde mi taxi saludos y abrazos para
todos montes javier muy bien javier
gonzález nunca cuidado con el tráfico
porque si mira el programa y estás
conduciendo el mismo creo que debe estar
aparcado
en méxico se roban bicicletas si pensar
pensar porque aquí las bicicletas son
más caras son más con más chinches
que las hacen pues más atractivas a mí
lo que me pareció en primero antes de
saludos al equipo de profesión a ser
seis dice rené betancourt
y otras a mí lo que pasó es rarísimo es
aquí en montreal tenemos es el sistema d
bicicletas que uno paga una mensualidad
y aquí la bici bueno encontraron una
bici en un país africano
cómo hicieron para sacar y para pedalear
hasta ese no me acuerdo cuál del país
africano
áfrica claro pero con un barco pero con
con qué permiso sube 11 una bicicleta
que tiene de la municipalidad
y bueno justamente con respecto a estas
bicicletas y al robo de bicicletas dice
acá la noticia que de 2000 entre 2014 y
2018 la policía de toronto recibió cerca
de 18 mil quejas relativas a los 18 mil
quejas en cuatro años así que bueno sí
ahí hay algo ahí hay un negocio hay un
negocio bueno yo les recuerdo a todos
ustedes que están allá del otro lado que
este es su programa y los invitamos muy
cordialmente a que nos envíen fotos que
nos envíen vídeos para pasarlos en el
programa y bueno pese podría ser una
parte de la colaboración de ustedes con
nosotros en este programa una bixi de
montreal en marruecos es afuera
y no se supo nunca cómo llegó pero había
una foto no sé si en este artículo está
la foto de las bicicletas bordadas en la
parte no no está no la vamos a ver así
que pero realmente llamativo porque para
que aparezca a marruecos con la extraña
seguridad desde la línea en las iglesias
bicis bueno leonardo en tu crees que sea
oportuno hablar un poco
la aplicación en realidad es siempre
oportuno y es siempre necesario y es un
pedido que le hacemos a la gente porque
aparte es súper simple bajar la
aplicación pueden ir directamente buscar
la aplicación es reciente pero está en
todas las lenguas ahí estamos haciendo
ese es el vídeo promocional y está en
todas las lenguas está en francés inglés
español en árabe y en chino y ustedes
pueden bajar la versión que más que les
sea es canción al exacto y dentro de la
aplicaciones en lenguas extranjeras es
decir español árabe y chino usted puedes
también ver las principales noticias en
francés y en inglés están solamente un
clic para ir a ver las mejores noticias
o más interesantes de las lenguas
oficiales canadienses así que la
invitación es ir a nuestra página hay un
icono en la parte derecha arriba que
esta semana en la semana que viene y
durante tres o cuatro semanas no va a
estar pero les digo que se pueden ir
ahora y no va a estar porque vamos a
poner las
en las publicidades para ir a ver toda
la preparación de las elecciones que se
vienen las elecciones canadienses en ese
espacio vamos a poner
digamos el vínculo para ir a visitar las
páginas de tbc y de radio canadá con
toda la información de la de las
elecciones en canadá así que pueden ir
ahora hacer clic en ese vínculo van a
entrar a una página donde tienen las dos
posibilidades tanto para apple como para
android entonces ustedes pueden ir hacer
clic y va directamente al kiosco de
apoyo de android para bajar la
aplicación en el idioma que ustedes sean
les recomendamos muy calurosamente y
fuertemente de que la bajen la
aplicación si es mucho más sencilla es
mucho más rápida en cuanto a la
capacidad de navegación y pueden mirar
este vídeo online en el mismo momento
está saliendo yendo a la parte de la
sección de vídeos y pueden ver el vídeo
si van a la aplicación con los días si
van a una aplicación mía
[Risas]
a olvidarlo bueno bueno tenemos tiempo
para leer los comentarios de nuestros
oyentes con respecto a nuestros
programas a nuestro programa nuestro
nuestro trabajo leonora que tienen ahí
tengo un comentario sobre una nota que
hice yo y que escribió ernesto y dice
pero que vergonzoso artículo me puso en
mi artículo se trata de el título del
artículo strong debería comprar a canadá
y no a groenlandia pero es realmente
irónico mucha ironía en el título
probablemente ernesto no conoce la
historia para decir me imagino esa
reacción que tuvo la historia es que
trampas el rato que quiere comprar
groenlandia como compro alaska con la
plata es que lo que está en juego es el
ártico la el ártico y quieren llegar
hasta el ártico y si es posible
apoderarse de todo el ártico entonces
propuso comprar groenlandia y dinamarca
le contestó que groenlandia ni los
habitantes como comprarlo
y lo que compraron a los rusos ahora que
quieren comprar entonces dinamarca
contestó ni los habitantes de
groenlandia ni el territorio están en
venta olviden olvidarte trump pero
entonces un profesor de eeuu un
estadounidense dijo que hay y lo hizo de
forma muy irónica y fue entrevistado por
si vice por el radiodifusor público
canadiense en inglés en un programa
de que en realidad a trump le convenía
le convenía a comprar más al territorio
canadiense a canadá a groenlandia y da
una serie de explicaciones porque ahora
que le conviene más no entonces eso es
un poco yo retome esa idea del profesor
este estadounidense hice una nota sobre
eso si existe una tendencia una gran
tendencia a
comentar el título y a veces el título
tiene elementos atractivos para que la
gente va a saber de otras noticias y 1
los goles exacto o por ejemplo la gente
que ve tratamiento o cura diabetes tipo
2 y nos manda más de mensajes
diciéndonos ayúdenme
denme el teléfono el nombre del
profesional y en el artículo está el
teléfono y el nombre de estacional
normalmente no sé si el teléfono pero el
nombre donde ubicarlos y la epilepsia
que es un profesor que está recibiendo
mensajes o claro pero es que no van
hasta el final del artículo y ahí está
es un profesor de saskatchewan de origen
mexicano eso es un es un gran gran
neurólogo y que estuvo haciendo una
investigación y quería que la gente
acudiera a él con preguntas y toda
américa latina en español proponía para
que él pues el dar sobre todo para
diagnosticar eso quería y bueno hay
gente que siguió los consejos está ahí
la dirección todo para escribirle pero
hay mucha gente que sigue preguntándoles
cómo hago que dice en fin cuando la
respuesta está en el reportaje está todo
esto sí a veces la gente no lee claro
nosotros también
a veces cuando uno tiene una persona
enferma y ve que un remedio milagroso
intenta rápido posible' lado pero por
ahí es bastante lógico también tomarse
un poquito más de tiempo y fijarse
porque por ahí los das las respuestas a
las exactas probablemente que están ahí
también y leonardo todos tienes por ahí
también algún mensaje en sí vamos a leer
un mensaje en este caso el ejército de
canadá levantaría requisitos de
ciudadanía para aumentar sus efectivos y
jonathan dice me gustaría pertenecer a
una fuerza tan prestigiosa como lo es
perdón la de canadá que es un país que
me encanta muy bonito agradable ese es
el mensaje que jonathan nos dejaba
entonces en nuestro sitio internet y yo
tengo acá se las quiero mostrar
[Aplausos]
y nos llega una carta desde
desde brasil
goya goya goya en brasil
nolan viajo ronaldo jose al baño pero al
menos pero no sé no entiendo muy bien su
caligrafía
pero mientras tanto también nos llegó
otra carta que viene de santiago de cuba
y ésta nos la envía rafael reyes plaza
en santiago de cuba así que les
agradecemos inmensamente que se sigan
recordando de nosotros por esos lares y
que nos escriban que se tomen el tiempo
porque hay que tomarse tiempo para
escribir una es una carta bastante larga
para
expresarnos como nos quieren
acabo de ver saluda héctor vilar la
sección brasileña
en lengua portuguesa y le vamos a mandar
una fotito en todo caso de instrucción
contacto con héctor para otro mensaje le
tengo este que es el titulo canadá
ofrece ayuda suplementaria para el
amazonas en reunión del g7 en francia
escribió patricia jancovic y dice
excelente trabajo de representantes del
g7 es lo que deben hacer por quienes les
votamos en cada país que vivimos gracias
radio canadá internacional sigan así
informando a quienes vivimos acá en
canadá a muy bien y yo difundiendo su
página a mi gente
leonardo si tengo otro mensaje en este
caso dice el primer ministro de albert
adquiere 40 mil inmigrantes que desean
establecerse en zonas rurales y raúl
hernández nos manda un mensaje diciendo
soy venezolano tengo 47 años
conocimiento de varios oficios a nivel
profesional mi inglés no es el mejor
pero me gustaría migrar con mi familia
esposa profesional de la educación y con
dos hijos varones menores los dos así
que le decimos a raúl hernández que la
información de inmigración también se
encuentra en nuestro sitio de internet
puntualmente si uno pone en migración
van a salir los
y artículos que hemos escrito sobre
inmigración y en esos artículos está
todas las implicaciones gracias muy bien
y hablando de inmigración servicios de
salud con o sin estatus migratorio en
montreal es uno de nuestros temas y raúl
ramírez dice hola no soy inmigrante
estoy de visita donde mi hija también
viene con la esperanza de que me ayuden
en mi situación de salud ya que en mi
problema de enfermedad rara no tengo un
alivio mi enfermedad disminuye cuando
camino y la debilidad aumenta por favor
me responden gracias ese es el tipo de
respuestas de preguntas a las que
nosotros no tengo individualmente le
podemos responder por simplemente no
tenemos respuesta exacta en el caso de
cuando hay cuestiones muy puntuales como
por ejemplo el tratamiento de las
mujeres que pedían el tratamiento para
los dientes en ontario eso es lo
contario y siempre le repetimos a la
gente que probablemente en cada país o
en las grandes ciudades haya planes
similares lo que si te diga que de todas
maneras en este reportaje
también está especificado que solamente
está dirigido a mujeres en situación
precaria económica en la provincia de
desafíos así que en este caso como el
mensaje de pablo habría que buscar
información para ver qué es lo que se
puede hacer pero nosotros puntualmente
no podemos estar en medio de esta de
esta situación
desafortunadamente tampoco tenemos el
tiempo de comenzar a rastrear ese tipo
de trabajos no se puede acá tengo otro
justamente es lo que hablábamos del
título neurólogo experto en epilepsia
ofrece consulta gratis en español desde
saskatchewan este es el título está
clarito ese título
sin embargo jessica poso dice buenas
tardes soy de peru quiero hacer una
consulta y es como que la consulta nos
las hace a nosotros y bueno habla de que
le hicieron exámenes a su hermano que en
fin explica todo el problema que tiene
entonces pide ayuda entonces le digo a
jessica si está escuchando el programa
que en ese mismo reportaje que ella
escribió a la dirección está
todas las coordenadas para conectarse
con el neurólogo en saskatchewan muy
bien tengo un mensaje aquí antonio
guterres se quiere organizar reunión
cumbre sobre la amazonas
era el tema y pedroso peña ir a la nos
mandó mensajes dice hola vivo en
paraguay yo creo que esto es la
respuesta a otro mensaje porque dice
hola vivo en paraguay no sé qué están
queriendo hacer meter la pata y culparme
por los incendios la gente dice lidiamos
con el paraná se ve culpable de muchas
otras cosas todas buenas por cierto pero
los los incendios no por favor que no se
me eche a mí y a mi pueblo la culpa de
tan severos acontecimientos se ofrezco
personal a la agua y maquinarias aquí en
nuestro país para socavar con todo ello
es una deserción y un pesar grandísimo
que se estén quemando y muriendo tan
preciosos árboles y animales como es lo
que está pasando en este momento saludos
desde la ciudad de luque y mi mejor
deseo y recursos a su disposición feliz
fin de año
un saludo el mensaje de pedro sopeña
irán muy bien bueno y el tiempo pasa
como agua entre los dedos entonces vamos
a ir con nuestros temas los temas que
destacamos esta semana que resaltamos en
nuestro programa y leonora vamos a
comenzar contigo tú nos hablas de hijas
e hijos de refugiados que toman el
relevo de sus padres así es pablo es una
historia que la encontré muy interesante
son dos jóvenes chicas jóvenes
canadienses hija de exiliados
latinoamericanos aquí en canadá que
llegaron en los 70 en los 80 una de
ellas es de origen chileno ella nació en
calgary la otra es de origen salvadoreño
nació en ontario y ambas asistieron a
una no sé si lo tenemos el reportaje si
ambas asistieron a una reunión en el mes
de marzo organizada por la universidad
eso es organizada por la universidad de
toronto en la cual en esa en esa mesa de
discusión en toronto se discutió de la
situación que están viviendo los
migrantes centroamericanos que salen de
los países que quieren venir a eeuu o
venir a canadá y hicieron un retrato
bastante sombrío de la situación había
gente de naciones unidas- del acnur más
precisamente que estaba presente en esa
reunión y por ejemplo dijeron que en el
año 2017
canadá sólo había acogido a 380 de los
25 mil pedidos solicitudes que había
para acoger a estos refugiados entonces
estas dos jóvenes estaban presentes en
la universidad de toronto y la pregunta
que hicieron en el panel fue qué es lo
que puede hacer canadá cómo puede canadá
contribuir no a acoger también a estos
refugiados entonces las dos jóvenes una
la que se llaman bueno a ver dónde están
los nombres que pamela arancibia y
mónica oviedo decidieron pasar a la
acción
directamente a ambas vienen dicen de
familias solidarias justamente por la
historia de sus padres decidieron pasar
a la acción y entonces crearon un
organismo y se hicieron conocer e
hicieron conocer a ese organismo
lanzando una petición y la petición fue
lanzada para los ciudadanos canadienses
y dirigida también al gobierno de canadá
a los ciudadanos canadienses porque
ellas dicen que muchos la mayoría de los
canadienses ignoran lo que está
sucediendo en américa central
el organismo que ellos han creado solo
para poner el nombre es la coalición
para el norte de centroamérica cnc a
entonces ellas explican
en esa solicitada de que el problema no
es que los migrantes quieren venir a
eeuu o canadá porque quieren mejorar su
situación económica sino que explican
que realmente hay como una situación de
guerra en esos países mucha violencia
persecución y entonces lo que ellos
dicen es que hay que tiene como dos
aspectos de esa petición
educar en educar a la población
canadiense sobre ese tema explicar e
iniciar una conversación sobre lo que
está pasando en américa central pero
también que sepan que los
centroamericanos que llegan aquí a
canadá como contribuyen al desarrollo de
esta sociedad porque muchas veces
tampoco se conoce mucho entonces eso y
por otro lado al gobierno canadiense le
están solicitando y de esta manera
ejerciendo presión para que reciban a
más refugiados durante esto entonces y
lo que ellas dicen es que esta coalición
finalmente está teniendo muchísimas son
muchas firmas en este momento lo que
ellas creen es que esta colisión va a
continuar porque hay mucho trabajo por
delante y pues me imagino que cada vez
están teniendo también más apoyo entre
jóvenes la mayoría de la coalición está
formada por centroamericanos y también
este sudamericanos pero todo el mundo
que quiera participar tiene las puertas
abiertas el reset punto sea ahí puede
encontrar el tema del que nos está
hablando
y más detalles sobre el trabajo que
están haciendo estas chicas este trabajo
solidario la continuación de lo que
hicieron sus padres aquí en canadá
leonardo gimeno tú nos hablas de
elecciones en eeuu y de problemas de
seguridad tecnológica y bueno cuyás en
la tele o en el pasaje ese es el tema
justamente lo que quieren hacer lo que
pretenden hacer las grandes tecnológicas
primero sin limpiar un poquito su nombre
que en realidad parece que no va a poder
acontecer porque todos los días aparece
una nueva filtración una nueva brecha de
seguridad en el caso de facebook que
hace dos o tres días 115 millones de
números de teléfono fueron de encontrar
una base de datos robado en hacker o sea
que seguimos todavía con un pequeño
problema de seguridad con este caso el
twitter gente twitter facebook microsoft
junto con la silla con homeland security
de eeuu hicieron una gran reunión
esta semana para ver cómo podían hacer
para encarar un plan de una estrategia
que fuera un poquito más con más cuerpo
y para evitar que pase lo que pasó en el
2016 o lo que se dice que pasó porque en
realidad nunca se comprobó que
efectivamente hubiera tenido algo que
ver pero se sospecha se cree y se vio
que hubieron ciertos resultados medios
bizarros pero todavía no se ha logrado
digamos encontrar un culpable y fue el
que el caso de cambridge analítica que
lo que pasó
cambridge analítica lo que hacía era
sacar facebook que había dado el ok para
que cierta información de una aplicación
pasara hacia una base de datos y
facebook se dio o vendió esa base de
datos a cambridge analítica lo que hizo
que a mucha analítica fue hacer un
análisis exhaustivo de toda esa
información y a partir de ese momento no
sólo en eeuu en una gran parte del mundo
pero puntualmente en avellaneda también
en argentina también en canadá también
para el break city de inglaterra
inglaterra la salida del europea todo
esto estuvo también contaminado con ese
tipo de información de la que fue robada
o no robada de la que fue filtrada de
facebook entonces por lo que están
tratando hacer es evitar que esto pase
de nuevo y la manera de hacerlo es
lograr que las estructuras de la
ingeniería de la computación en esas
grandes plataformas de ese facebook le
hace twitter
google microsoft que traten de evitar la
filtración para que no se pueda hacer lo
que se hizo que fue puntualmente en lo
que se les dice en eeuu fue que esta
información fue utilizada para segmentar
pero muy muy el detalle de la gente que
todavía no estaba decidida a quien votar
se veía cuáles eran sus charlas cuáles
qué
qué lugares frecuenta entonces es
manipular entonces le mandaban mensajes
puntuales a esa persona diciendo lo que
querían escuchar y llevándolos hacia
determinada diego de voto quería saber
entonces lo que quieren evitar es que
esto pase de nuevo limpiar un poco la
credibilidad y que las elecciones en el
2020 sean quizás un poquito más
transparentes de lo que fueron en el año
2016 y en el 2016 bueno claramente en
otro sistema hubiera ganado hilar y
clinton que tuvo más votos tuvo más de
un millón de votos que tras eso es eso
tiene que ver con la manera en que está
armada organizada las elecciones y eso
es otra historia pero ganó el voto
popular clinton es lo que le dicen el
voto popular igual que el verde como se
llamaba el que después fue
vicepresidente de clinton
y también sobre el medio ambiente
pero este vicepresidente también lo
obtuvo cuando se presentó a la
presidencia a la carrera presidencial
había obtenido más votos que el hijo del
otro presidente estadounidense
se había presentado contra
esas son las trampas de un sistema que
es muy añejo el de estados unidos de la
época de la que viene de la sencillito
esté tratando de pensar en el nombre de
6 yo hice una película súper conocida
para que sigan pensando yo antes de que
se me olvide a mí quiero recordar algo
gustavo luque caramba que nos ayudan
en los controles técnicos hoy vendieron
carburante
permitir antes de que el reportante que
presente me reportaré porque no va a
quedar mucho tiempo
[Música]
en este caso con un mensaje de gustavo
luques y particularmente escucho todos
los problemas de res y el viernes pasado
alumnos estuvo con stefan paran en el
programa en francés y enseguida también
escuché el de ustedes no entiende el
idioma pero les escrita en francés y
ellos me han respondido dice y miriam
al arco hablando sin mirada con ese
hermoso recibir cartas o intercambios
postales me hace feliz bueno muy bien y
muy rápidamente pues yo los quiero
invitar a escuchar una entrevista que
hice como un cineasta quebequense que se
llama julián él lee en su película se
llama el le soleil no hay soles negros
que ese es un documental que dura dos
horas y media más o menos y en el que
presenta la problemática de las
desapariciones forzadas en méxico
entonces el primero quería hacer un
programa sobre los feminicidios pero
finalmente después se dio cuenta en el
camino que no había sólo las mujeres
desaparecidas sino que hay también
periodistas desaparecidos en niños
desaparecidos en fin entonces el pse que
hizo esta película para darnos una idea
global del problema que está sucediendo
en méxico y ese fue todo el tiempo del
que disponíamos para este
en las américas
ya fue presentada el documental el
documental se presentó el 3 de
septiembre y comenzó a caer aquí en el
metro en méxico se va a presentar el 27
de septiembre así que comentar muy
valioso el reportaje la entrevista que
hice que es muy interesante con julien
en live quien nos hable yo le pregunté
por qué soles negros y ese porte cuando
se piensa en méxico se piensa en el sol
la playa y el tequila y nada más
entonces es dicen bueno se hace parte de
la tragedia no los olés negros y eso fue
todo por cada en las américas café los
invitamos a que regresen nuevamente con
nosotros el 10 del próximo y que visiten
nuestro sitio internet ahí está todo
nuestro trabajo les deseamos un feliz
fin de semana y será hasta la próxima
aquí
[Música]